ils souvenir est ce qu'on a vraiment
détruire souvenir
[Musique]
je veux savez bande de connards ne faut
pas plus grand abattoir
tu aimes ou tu es surpris par son
ampleur plus de vous j'en peux plus de
vous je voulais pas la faire je savais
que telle connerie pour paris voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
tandis que les conneries tu conduis pas
de deviner
éloignez pas de vide et on t'aime
c'est l'opinion
j'aime bien mais c'est pas grave mais
c'est sorti douze nicolau reliés à la
lumière et tour eux et avec un système
seront surtout franchement comme ça
c'est de la magie
[Musique]
oui mais voilà non même si quand ils
retournent qui fait ça mais c'est
incroyable qui ait eu cette idée d'aller
d'abus tout le monde tombe dans le piège
[Musique]
je peux plus me voir mais non mais je
rêve
c'est encore une idée d'hanouna forme
maintenant bien sûr je peux plus te voir
serré je ne peux plus te voir en plus
d'être sûr qu'on va dire le chocolat en
fait la turquie un moment on va dire
chocolat et tout est là dans le coin du
sel
évidemment je sers bien sûr bon ben je
prends vous vous dire merci
non pas de problème mais parti d'où le
jeu connaît en fait non mais
[Musique]
c'est un génie l'autre carrière non mais
attends si vous commencez vous encourage
leur disant que c'est un truc de génie
alors là on est non sans jamais un
chapeau en fait j'ai bien fait mon
chapeau ouais tu vois comme quoi être
coquette
ça peut sembler des trucs tu es là toi
[Rires]
à les croire mais je ne crois même pas
je ne crois même pas les bonifications
jean lavallée formés mais tu es ici oui
comment mexico
mon dieu bon bah c'est pas tout ça les
sorties cdn je savais dans ma tête j'ai
dit à la maquilleuse me maquille pas
trop je sais à quoi m'attendre d'un élu
jeudi la mutation
c'est beaucoup ce fut un plaisir
c'est pourquoi j'aurais des frais jugés
fraises
oui des loisirs des filles emma lehmann
et main et maintenant on a en a 2 5
millions pour changer sa vie pour le
l'émission comment on fait pour être à
l'heure
je vois rien chaque fois que nous les
gens me merci tu diriges ce qu'a annoncé
une boîte
[Musique]
la première fois qu'on s'est pris ce que
là bas
[Musique]
comment je peux me faire avoir et
mafieuses qui n'ait gardé fra nce est
pour toi tu m'étonnes écoute moi bien
richard mais qu'est ce que t'es un pc
dell mini 5 en souvenir
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est vraiment ça qui m'a fait la veille
je m'habitue m'a appelé c'est ce qui m'a
fait bizarre c'est long texto coucou
monsieur wada ne te plaît pas crois-tu
pouvoir te libérer évidemment selon des
horaires ton emploi du temps chargé de
l'animateur producteur selon ce qui
t'arrange on se déplacera quartier
génial qu'est-ce qui mène 7 filles ont
démontré à l'époque
et quand même hein c'est pas un
rendez-vous à telle heure tu voyais de
l'homme de match je te rappelle et tout
ça tu es vraiment je sais quoi ça
continue un [ __ ] et je vais dernier
par les agents de la paix n'a rien dit
c'est
merci connaissent je suis ton sourire
gardes pour toi ballon si beau salut aux
malades ou shot
sur un plan plus dur diversité heureux
dit merci
honnêtement je pense que je crée mes
notes à bagnols / tard jo ça colle c'est
où la douce là bas salaires et finir
dans la liesse que quand allez vous
envoyez des choix voulu me faire avoir
osé les défier tous les pièges d'une
chaude heures ah oui non et l'argent des
vaisseaux et cette annonce a fait ça me
tue rather than beaucoup son journal
dont plus tard puis je bois mon pote
non c'est parce que j'allais avocat
américain veut dire quelque chose avec
j'aurais dit mais des permanenciers
j'avais pas de téléphone aura une des